[موسيقى]
لقد كنت في إزمير
لساعات فقط
، وقد تم الترحيب بي بحرارة من
قبل سيدات مجموعة الدراجات النسائية الفاخرة
اللواتي يغنين أغاني لا أعرفها
ولكن يبدو أن الهمهمة تعمل بشكل جيد
[  موسيقى]
مدينة سميرنا القديمة
اليوم إزمير هي ثالث أكبر مدينة في تركيا
يسمونها لؤلؤة
شعب بحر إيجه الذين استقروا على
هذه
الشواطئ منذ حوالي ثمانية آلاف عام
مرحبًا بك في إسرائيل ، من الرائع أن أكون
هنا
[موسيقى]
قد يكون ركوب الدراجات هنا  ممتع
ولكن عند ركبتي المفصلية ، فإن المشي السريع
على طول الكورنيش سيفي بالغرض أيضًا ،
فمن الجيد أن تشعر بالشمس على الوجه
بعد شتاء طويل قاسٍ
وحتى لو لم ترتفع درجات الحرارة هنا في
إزمير بعد وهناك
نسيم سريع  قبالة بحر إيجه ،
إنها الطريقة المثلى لبدء زيارتي
إلى تركيا الغربية
[موسيقى]
أنا هنا قبل وصول جحافل السياح
بينما لا يزال الطقس
جيدًا والطعام الجيد إنها حياة جيدة
ويبدأ اليوم بأطعمة محلية جيدة
فقط  ليكون فو  هنا في مخبز إزمير
المصنوع يدويًا ،
نقوم بذلك بالطريقة التقليدية
التي تتطلب مهارة
وخبرة للحصول على الرحلات الصحيحة.
من اللذيذ أكلها
[موسيقى]
تحدٍ مثالي إذا سمعت
يومًا ما يحرج نفسي من الذهاب على
افتراض أنه يمكنني صعود هذه السلالم شديدة الانحدار
تلك الركبتين مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
لذلك لا يحتوي الكلب إلا على ماء طحين
وملح لذلك  سيقلب الكلب
في الهواء ،
هذه هي الطريقة التي من المفترض أن يتم القيام
بها ، كل شيء في ذاكرة العضلات
للخباز الرئيسي ، ولا توجد وصفة مطلوبة
، وكل شخص مصنوع يدويًا ،
ولكن لا يمكن لآلات الزمن أن تجعله
لا يوجد آلة لصنع الدمامل
حيث  هل يأتي هذا بعد أن
ينتمي الدمامل إلى مطبخ اليهود المشبع ،
انتقلوا إلى إزمير منذ
أكثر من 400 عام ،
لذلك
عندما يأتون ، يجلبون
ثقافتهم بالفعل ومطبخهم في الواقع
منذ ذلك
الحين  حلج زيوت القرن العشرين
ينتمي إلى إزمير
مع الأخذ في الاعتبار أنهم يصنعون 1500 من
هذه الزيوت يوميًا ، وهذا يعني أنه يجب أن
يكون هناك 10 زيوت في العراق ، لذلك هناك 150 منها
يجب القيام
بها وحتى اللحظة التي كنا ننتظرها
سأحاول ألا أخيب
أملك ، نعم ، نعم ، نعم ،
حسنًا ، تسير الأمور على ما يرام هناك ، نذهب ،
أوه ،
إذا أحدثت فوضى ، يجب عليك ترتيبها ،
ولم
تشك حتى في
أنه من المفترض أن تطول المدة ،
لكنها في الواقع تصبح أصغر حجمًا
انتبه إذا قمت بنسخ مثل هذا ،
فلدي أخبار سيئة لأنك
ستخرج من العمل
إذا قمت بذلك ، فأنا محرج تقريبًا
من تقديم هذا إلى الفرن
[موسيقى] ،
دعنا نفترض أنني لن أسقط  اسفل هذه
السلالم واقتل نفسي ، تعال
بينما أنتظر سيكون من الوقاحة عدم
أخذ عينات من البضائع ،
أوه ، هذا أكثر سخونة مما كنت أعتقد
أنه سيكون
[موسيقى]
من مثل طفل لا يمكنك الانتظار ،
أنا أدفع العواقب  فمي
محترق الآن
لدي شوكولاتة في كل مكان
ولا يمكنني إيقاف
دفعي جاهز والدليل
سيكون في البودنغ أو إذا كنت
ستغلي ، فلنسأل
أيهم لي
وأيهم الطهاة أراهن أنك لا
تستطيع معرفة الفرق ، نعم
بالطبع يمكنني أن هؤلاء هم لك هؤلاء هم
رؤسائنا
[ضحك  ]
ما هي الكلمة الوحيدة
التي ستصفها إزمير ،
كيف تصف هذه الوجبة ،
نحن محظوظون جدًا في إسرائيل لأن
حياتنا تقضي عطلتها